І роби все, що я роблю, такі ж рухи, гаразд?
Ти точно мене підштовхнув, Максе.
Це ніби НЛО, друзі.
Приємно познайомитись.
Це якась сумнівна дурня.
Це всередині мосту.
Спостерігаючи за всіма автобусами.
Виглядає так само, як у Прип'яті (місто у Чорнобилі).
І ось знову.
Глибоко під Києвом, у ядерному бункері.
Але сьогодні
Макс приведе нас на покинуту автобусну станцію,
яка спершу не видалась цікавою.
Але він переконав мене, що це не так.
Ми повинні перелізти через це, так?
Майже, так.
Ми наближаємося до місця, яке нам потрібне.
Тому, Пітере, я хотів би попросити тебе про дещо.
Говори лише тоді, коли я скажу, гаразд?
Це порушення закону, Максе?
Взагалі-то, ні. У нашій країні це не вважається порушенням закону.
Це ніби порушення володінь, але ніхто не скаже тобі й слова.
Справді?
Вони можуть лише попросити тебе покинути їхню територію, і все.
Це максимум того, що вони можуть зробити.
Але для нас це не проблема.
Ми заходимо і робимо свою справу тим часом.
Ми робимо свою справу, тобто
показуємо, настільки дике це місце.
Димова труба, колючий дріт.
Зніми це.
Я хочу пересвідчитися, що там відбувається.
З моїм старим входом досі все гаразд. Він досі готовий до використання.
Здається, навіть мої рукавиці досі тут.
Ти залишаєш тут пару рукавиць щоразу?
Так.
Я можу передати.
Чудово.
Ставати просто туди?
Так.
Що ж, це не було ідеально.
Давай заспокоїмося.
Давай нормалізуємо дихання і потім продовжимо.
Тут є лабіринт старих поржавілих автобусів.
Наша мета - пройти довгий шлях крізь них,
щоб потрапити в коло.
Головний об'єкт, який нам потрібен.
Не говори багато і роби все, що я роблю, такі ж рухи, гаразд?
Гаразд.
Бачиш, краще, ніж Чорнобиль.
Ну що ж, Пітере, ти готовий до пригод?
Так, давай зробимо це.
Поки що лише кілька покинутих автобусів.
Там внизу осередок гопників?
Просто смітник. Ходімо.
Думаю, як спуститися.
найкращим чином.
Ми можемо просто зістрибнути сюди, так?
Як професіонал, краще, ніж я.
Це класний кадр.
Що сталося з цими автобусами? Коли їх вививели з ужитку, вони опинилися тут?
Так.
Це будівля охорони. Охоронець може бути всередині або ні.
Думаю, що ні, через карантин.
Що з охоронцем?
Він нормальний?
Не знаю.
Тут постапокаліптична атмосфера.
Дуже...
похмуро, але цікаво.
Багато мастила на землі, багато сміття.
Але вони досить блискучі. Я не бачив таких автобусів, такого плану.
Не загубись.
Не загубися в автобусах?
Не йди першим.
Я бачив, як чоловік проходив ось там, вкінці.
Тут ми в безпеці. Ніхто нас не побачить у цьому лабіринті металу.
Максе, що тут було? Це місце для обслуговування усього цього?
Різні приміщення для обслуговування автобусів. Старі правила безпеки.
Радянських часів, так?
Oригінальні плакати безпеки.
Чому вони не віддають метал? Не забирають і не продають його?
Тому що він належить державі.
Це круто.
Тут нам потрібно бути тихими.
Тобто, тут вони міняли мастило?
Так.
Добре, що якщо ти почуєш когось здалеку,
ти маєш достатньо часу, щоб зникнути серед цих автобусів.
Тому що це величезна територія, і ніхто не шукатиме тебе.
Колись вони мали навіть центр управління отам.
Там був стіл і величезне скло, величезне вікно.
Там була відповідальна особа, начальник цієї станції.
Він міг спостерігати за всією цією територією. Які автобуси прибувають, які відправляються.
Краплі води створюють звук,
різні звуки.
І початківці в індустріальному туризмі
зазвичай лякаються цих звуків. Вони думають, що хтось йде, що це охоронець.
Але коли ти займаєшся цим довгий час, ти вже знаєш,
як зрозуміти, чи це охоронець, чи це краплі води.
Коли ми були в тунелях,
там була зовсім інша екосистема звуків.
Коли ми вийшли в місто, і там було ніби...
Чуєш удар металу? Можливо, це через нагрівання. Стискання і розширення.
Так, дійсно.
Круто.
Найкращий вид.
Куди йдемо далі?
Спершу, я хотів би потрапити туди.
А потім туди. Бачиш?
Не знаю, коли ви це переглядаєте.
Але зараз липень,
11 липня.
2020 рік.
Ми у розпалі коронавірусу.
Життя на вулицях не завмерло, поки люди носять маски.
Насправді, зараз є найбільший ризик. Я намагався подумати про
ідеї для відео,
для більшості яких необхідно бути подалі від людей.
На щастя, я зустрів Макса.
Немає шляху нагору, Максе?
Чорт!
Обережно.
Ось яким потрібно бути в 42.
Що?
Ось так ти повинен поводитися, коли тобі 42.
Ні, це точно не те, як ти повинен поводитися, коли тобі 42.
Хтось підклав ці вогнегасники сюди.
Це дуже погана ідея.
Моя дружина була ніби... Я сказав: "Я йду до Макса".
Знову.
Я сказав: "Я йду до Макса знову".
На якусь покинуту автостанцію.
І я думаю, про те, щоб сказати їй:
"Скажи своїй мамі, коли вона подивиться це, що це не небезпечно"
Не хочу, щоб її мама хвилювалася. Тому що, розумієш, чоловік її доньки повзає біля автобусів.
Вона сказала: "Що ж, ти не на Середньому Сході". Тому моя мама з СССР зовсім не переймається.
Вона просто звикла до цього.
Відеблогерство ще ніколи не було таким складним.
Індустріальний туризм у віці.
Чи є нагороди у сфері індустріального туризму у вікових категоріях, типу 70+?
Тут круто. Що це?
Ліцензії. Посвідчення.
Яка це книга?
Довговічність двигунів.
Відмінне робоче місце.
Радянські шахи.
Круто.
І журнал з різними правилами.
Розклади, автобуси.
Виглядає так само, як у Прип'яті.
Стан на 100% такий, як у Прип'яті.
Як я казав раніше, усі просто пішли звідси одного дня, так?
Нестача фінансування. Це єдина проблема в Україні.
Усі колишні радянські заводи, інститути,
лабораторії, що-завгодно, - усе стає покинутим
через нестачу
фінансування.
Тобто, якось вони вирішили зачинитися і просто пішли?
Так, справді.
Просто вийшли за двері.
Ходи сюди. Центр управління.
Отже, адміністратор сидів тут на зеленому стільці,
спостерігаючи
за всіма автобусами, за всіма робітниками,
щоб упевнитись, що всі працівники виконують усе правильно.
Я завжди хотів знайти десь тут маленький бункер, але ні.
Жодних ядерних бункерів тут.
Це центр медичної допомоги.
Чому тут був центр медичної допомоги?
Кожен великий завод, інститут, кожна автостанція мала власний центр медичної допомоги.
Поглянь сюди. Це для перевірки зору.
Тепер ми йдемо до кільця.
Це головна частина, так?
Нам потрібно бути тихими, тому що інколи охоронець сидить тут всередині.
Це круто.
Спробуй не дуже світити тут.
Давай скористаємося іншим входом. Це не найкращий.
Максе, нам потрібен інший шлях, так? Смердить мастилом.
Це нагадує екологічну катастрофу, це точно.
Охорона?
Вимкни світло.
Вони могли б зробити тут щось класне.
Вивглядає ніби НЛО.
Це ніби НЛО, друзі.
У колишньому СССР можна побачити багато прикладів цікавої архітектури.
Навіть у таких утилітарних місцях, як це.
Автобусне депо.
Місце для ремонту.
Це могло б бути чим-завгодно.Тут могла б бути концертна зала.
Або величезний базар.
Тут є вікна в даху, які пропускають денне світло.
І неймовірні розміри.
Хочеш побачити захід сонця з верхівки даху? Ходімо.
Це один з багатьох аспектів життя на Заході.
Ми не знали
про таку
цікаву архітектуру.
Серед неї багато прикладів бруталізму, вона досить масивна і сувора.
але...
Звісно, це місце потребує реновації, але де ви востаннє бачили таку лінію даху?
Гарно, чи не так?
Так гарно.
І зовсім без охорони.
Максе, це одне з твоїх улюблених місць у Києві?
Це закрита територія, еге ж?. Ми тут не пройдемо.
Секретне місце. Кілька років тому
власноруч я зробив вхід на дах.
Це те, що я зробив.
Це воно, так?
Так.
Що ж, друзі, ми досягли верхівки.
Ось що на верхівці.
Виглядає ніби пустеля з чорним піском, але це дах, друзі.
З маленькими деревами.
Неймовірно, що тут ростуть дерева.
Що було тут раніше, ось тут, нагорі?
Це вентиляція.
Що це за будівля отам, старий завод?
Це не завод, це частина цієї автостанції, головна адміністративна будівля.
Ми заходимо. Звідси виходить дуже сильний потік повітря.
Це величезний простір.
Це інше "вперше". Я мав чимало таких "вперше" у цьому місці, та в цій країні також.
Речі, які ти уявити не міг.
Тобі потрібно відчути це. Ось чому мені тут подобається, якщо чесно.
Багато відкриттів.
Ти сказав, що хочеш ще кудись піти.
Я хотів перевірити іншу можливість.
Я чув, що зараз один з мостів Києва доступний для відвідування.
Чи вдасться нам це зробити?
Думаю, так.
Макс відведе нас туди, просто на верхівку.
Виглядає ніби лапки павука.
Вид згори неймовірний.
Нині цей міст має назву "Північний".
Як почуваєшся, Максе?
Почуваюся втомленим, виснаженим, але щасливим, бо існує вхід.
Це всередині мосту.
Підходимо ближче.
Ти боїшся висоти?
Не дуже.
Якось я привів сюди свого друга, і він дійсно був наляканий.
О так, це прекрасно.
Ще один рівень.
Це якась сумнівна дурня.
Що це означає?
Типу страхітливий, насторожений, нестабільний.
Дивакуватий? Але це дуже добре для ніг.
Це добре для голови. Насправді, заспокоює.
Привіт!
Привіт.
Звідки ти?
Я зі США.
А звідки ви?
Рука злочину Максимович (Макс).
Матінко рідна!
Як справи?
Ви іноземці?
Так.
Звідки ти?
З Америки.
Приємно познайомитися.
Можеш розмовляти англійською, якщо хочеш.
Я знаю російську.
Ти приїхав до Києва, щоб лазити?
Взагалі-то, ні.
Я тут ніби випадково опинився.
Нічого собі. Подивіться на це.
Ну як, Пітере, я тобі допоміг? Ти поборов свої страхи?
Ти точно мене підштовхнув, Максе.
Що ж, це кінець відео.
Якщо ви хочете, щоб вас підштовхнули у Києві,
це ваша людина, Макс.
Я залишу його Інстаграм внизу.
Він вас добряче налякає.
Відведе у цікаві місця.
Змусить вас відчути себе живими, якщо ви не помрете. Не тут, друже.
До наступного відео.
Ми руфери. Ми досліджуємо усе місто та інші міста Ураїни. Ми любимо це до нестями.
Друзі, я не можу це пояснити. У мене запаморочення. Я ніколи не думав, що боюся висоти.